[Musique]
bonjour Le Figaro bienvenue nous sommes
en direct aujourd'hui pour vous faire
vivre un événement vous l'avez vu c'est
la sonde juice qui va décoller pour
appareil qui fait avec Cyril Vandenberg
bonjour Cyril rédacteur chef du service
sciences on va discuter avec vous de ce
qui se passe de cette sonde alors on l'a
vu elle va décoller à 14h14 et elle va
vers Jupiter oui oui c'est une mission
vraiment spéciale c'est l'avant dernier
vol d'Ariane 5 et donc c'est la mission
spatiale la plus excitante la plus
ambitieuse aussi l'agence principale de
la décennie donc c'est
pour tous les scientifiques et pour tous
ceux qui aiment l'exploration du système
solaire c'est c'est quelque chose à
suivre face à un grand moment c'est un
grand moment et on va le vivre ensemble
là vous voyez on est encore alors c'est
marrant parce que la NASA normalement
pas il faut des lancements on voit leur
refuser tout le long ah ça y est on la
voit pas de tir à Kourou donc en Guyane
c'est alors c'est un dessert à l'école
qui aurait dû avoir lieu hier à la base
oui à la même heure hier 10 minutes
avant le décollage c'était interrompu à
cause de la météo il y avait un risque
d'orage qui était risque de de foudre
qui était trop peu trop élevé
et là pour le moment tous les voyants
sont ouverts oui on l'a vu on l'a vu
effectivement
[Musique]
pour chaque lancement il y a deux
paramètres qui sont importants en Guyane
c'est pas la pluie c'est pas le nuage
c'est les risques de foudre donc sur le
papier au décollage
et et aussi l'autre des éléments à haute
altitude qui peuvent dévier d'excuser
donc là pour le moment tout est bon
parce que c'est quand même un lancement
qui est très important qui a coûté très
cher et est-ce qu'on peut rappeler déjà
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire sur Jupiter
alors oui oui c'est une mission qui
coûte un milliard
1,6 milliards d'euros c'est donc c'est
une mission qui est en opération depuis
plus de 10 ans et qui va aller autour ce
qui va se mettre en orbite autour du
Jupiter pour aller observer trois des
quatre grandes lunes de cette planète
géante donc Jupiter c'est la plus grosse
planète du système solaire c'était un
monstre c'est c'est
300 fois la masse de la planète Terre et
il y a des lunes qui sont entre en
taille qui sont plus grosses que notre
Lune et qui sont certaines presque aussi
grosses que Mars et elles ont des trucs
incroyables c'est les ont des océans de
d'eau liquide caché sous une croûte
glacée il y a plus de liquides alors
j'ai vu qu'il y avait plus de liquide
chez elle que sur terre oui on a il y a
deux des lunes Europe et ganymen dans le
sur lequel on est sûr que ces océans
soutiennent ils contiennent plus d'eau
que tout ce qu'on a sur les autres
s'intéresse donc c'est et ça attire
incroyablement les astronautes les
astronomes par exemple astronautes qui
restent sur terre ils attendent mais non
le les astronautes sont excités parce
que si on pense que c'est aujourd'hui
l'environnement dans le système solaire
qui est le plus favorable à la possible
apparition de vie
on a passé pas mal d'expéditions sur sur
Mars les mars
c'est sec c'est désolé c'est une surface
qui est totalement stérile qui est même
stérilisé par les composants qui sont à
la surface donc on sait qu'on trouvera
peut-être des traces de vie fossiles sur
Mars un jour peut-être la vie qui a
existait il y a 4 milliards d'années
quand la planète était plus humide mais
aujourd'hui il y a aucune chance de
trouver la vie sur Mars
et donc il faut aller chercher ailleurs
et ailleurs c'est donc ces cellules de
Jupiter elle s'appelle Europe
Ganymède et Kalisto il y a aussi une
lune autour de Saturne qui a aussi un
océan souterrain c'est en cela donc
c'est quatre lunes là c'est c'est fait
partie des cibles favorites de
l'exploration
du système solaire c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui excite incroyablement
les scientifiques alors on m'a demandé
c'est vrai marin qui m'a dit de qu'on
pouvait pas voir le timer vous le voyez
décollage prévu dans moins de 5 minutes
vous ne voyez nous tout en bas parce que
c'est pas très important et vous voyez
surtout en bas à droite le le direct là
on voit la fusée qui est mise en place
avant qu'elle parte on imagine que ça
c'est quand même du boulot de travail et
la campagne de avant le lancement et
dure plus d'un mois peut-être entre le
moment où les éléments de la fusée
arrivent d'Europe ils arrivent par
bateau
les boosters donc les accélérateurs à
poutres qui sont sur le côté on voit un
Antonov donc ça l'Antonov il apporte les
satellites il appelait la portée la
sonde donc le son du Joyce
c'est une sonde c'est elle fait au
décalage je vais faire un petit tonnes
donc c'est une grosse masse pour une
mission lointaine comme ça on est on
pousse les capacités d'Ariane 5 au
maximum et sur les 6 tonnes il y a plus
de la moitié de la masse c'est du
carburant du carburant il est important
pour pour surtout pour une fois qu'on
arrive à Jupiter avoir assez d'énergie
pour freiner cette envie et donc et donc
on voit on la voit ici on voit les
panneaux solaires repliés on voit les
parties métalliques et là elles sont sur
les côtés
d'immense panneaux solaires qui font des
plus
grandes basket les plus grands panneaux
solaires jamais envoyé pour une mission
d'exploration du système solaire parce
que si on envoie une son il faut qu'elle
puisse se débrouiller par eux alors j'ai
vu aussi que on l'envoie elle va partir
directement sur Jupiter elle va faire
quelques petits tours pour prendre de
l'élan quelques quelques grands tours
oui il y a quatre survols qui sont
prévus
trois avec la terre et un avec Vénus
pour pour donner plus d'énergie et
accélérer la sonde et lui permettre
d'aller jusqu'à Jupiter
et le voyage va durer presque 8 ans
il faudrait vraiment une fusée beaucoup
beaucoup plus puissante pour pour aller
plus vite donc là en fait on est lié un
peu limités par la mécanique orbitale
pour aller vers les planètes lointaines
il faut de la vitesse il faut et cette
vitesse en fait c'est un cancer de
l'effet de fronde en passant proche de
la Terre proche de Vénus plusieurs
reprises et au total ça fait un voyage
de 6,6 milliards de km 6,6 20 km et
pareil on l'envoie maintenant elle va
arriver dans 8 ans et donc voilà dans 8
ans en 2031 j'espère que vous serez là
on fera un live ensemble
et on se dit qu'on fera on fera ensemble
à ce moment-là 2031 donc il va falloir
être patient
2031 c'est la mise en orbite pour
Jupiter là c'est l'opération pareil
c'est au bout de 8 ans de voyage et de
toute façon parfaite état il faut
qu'elle fonctionne que les moteurs
poussent correctement
voilà donc ça sera le grand rendez-vous
dans 8 ans avec une vraiment une
émission scientifique les plus
excitantes depuis des années à l'agence
spati européenne alors on va regarder ce
qui se passe des images là c'est le
centre de contrôle qu'on voyait on voit
aussi dans le public parce qu'il y avait
du bruit c'est le faux centre de
contrôle
c'est le centre de contrôle qui est
présenté au public et on voit les VIP là
ils sont sur le sur les balcons à
l'extérieur regarde la fusée qui est
pour eux elle a plus de 12 km donc elle
est
un peu loin un peu loin mais on entend
quand même au décalage
on a triste
il est sur un site d'observation qui est
le plus proche du pas de tir je crois
qu'il est entre 5 et 6 km voilà
si d'observation qui s'appelle Toucan
donc lui je pense qu'il va voir un
spectacle si ça décolle on voit tous les
voyants sont au centre alors là on voit
sur l'écran là c'est tous les contrôles
il faut que tout soit au vert il suffit
d'un voyant rouge la météo après une
batterie sur la sonde les moteurs de la
fusée tout tout est vérifié oui parce
qu'on peut pas se permettre d'avoir un
problème sur une sonde qui a demandé
autant de travail et autant de voilà
donc on voit on voit les responsables de
la mission des responsables du
là on voit surtout un responsable du pas
de tir donc le pâtir il est géré par le
CNES l'agence spatiale française donc
c'est une mission de l'Agence spatiale
mais quand on décolle en Guyane on est
sur territoire français et la
responsabilité du lancement et les
Françaises d'ailleurs voilà on les
entend parler en France
pour ce décollage on va vous faire vivre
bien sûr au moment du décollage on fera
vivre les images en plein pot forcément
pour que vous pouviez pouvoir voir un
peu ce qui va se passer 40 secondes ça
on imagine toujours des grands moments
parce que un décollage c'est c'est
extraordinaire et là et là c'est une
mission sur lequel les scientifiques ont
bossait depuis 10 ans donc il doit y
avoir une tension incroyable une vraie
un suspense terrible c'est pas c'est pas
une mission comme les autres je peux
vous assurer que quand on a passé autant
de sa vie pour travailler construire les
instruments prévoir la mission
et voilà et de revivre ce lancement on
voulait vivre les 10 dernières secondes
8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 top
allez ma jolie
ce décollage on vient on voit ces images
c'est toujours très très impressionnant
alors magnifique tu as rien de 5 et là
le temps est très couvert donc on passe
directement dans les nuages et on voit
plus que la flamme des moteurs et deux
accélérateurs à poudre sur les côtés et
le moteur Vulcain en centre la poussée
au maximum on a déjà franchi
une étape clé
la partie de l'accélération ou la
pression ergonomique est la plus forte
la fusée
la structure travaille le plus
donc là ça y est on ne verra plus la
fusée a priori on est parti elle est
partie vu que c'est nuageux on peut pas
voir plus non et le temps est couverts
les enfants sur l'eau qui était marrant
le spectacle
on essaie de voir
c'est magnifique ça aussi
on essaie d'avoir quelque chose qui soit
très spectaculaire au vendurance avec
beaucoup de caméras pour immortaliser ça
oui oui il y a toujours il y a toujours
des photographes officielles des
photographes il y a du il y a du monde
et le décollage c'est passer la
libération incroyable le décollage pour
sortir pour sortir de la façon terrestre
les 500 tonnes derrière 5 c'est
extraordinaire
quand on est à 10 km on sent le bruit et
les vibrations et le corps entier vibre
donc c'est 50 une puissance qui est
vraiment qui dépasse ce serait largement
la séparation des boosters au bout de 2
minutes donc ils ont fait la maximum du
travail qui est faite qui est
d'accélérer la fusée
et la sortir des couches les plus
épaisses de l'atmosphère et on voit déjà
que la trajectoire c'est assez réel la
trajectoire s'incline et le but de la
fusée c'est d'avoir le plus de vitesse
par rapport à l'horizon
d'accorder tout droit mais plutôt de
courber pour exactement et là voilà la
vitesse de cet utilisation c'est pas une
vitesse verticale c'est une vitesse
horizontale par rapport au sol donc en
fait il faut le but de la fusée là il y
a le moteur électrique
c'est de tourner le plus vite possible
on fait on décolle verticale pour
s'extraire des couches les plus denses
de l'atmosphère
une fois qu'on est au-dessus de cette
couche là on incline et on commence à à
partir vers l'horizontale pour avoir le
plus de vitesse et et au final c'est la
vitesse qui fait la statisation oui
c'est la vitesse
on va montrer d'ailleurs séparation de
la coiffe donc là on est on est à plus
de 90 km d'altitude on est dans la on
est dans l'espace donc il y a plus de
pression aérodynamique on peut enlever
la coiffe qui protège la sonde on voit
sur ces images de synthèse on voit juice
décollage dans la moitié de carburant
est-ce que la si quelque chose se passe
mal on saura ou pas il y a toujours la
télémétrie on le voit sur ce petit
schéma là avec la courbe jaune qui est
en haut de l'image en fait ça c'est la
c'est la courbe
altitude
et distance et donc ça si on a une
légère déviation de cette courbe prévue
et ben c'est pas bon signe et tout ça
c'est c'est donné par les éléments de la
télémétrie du bord donc on est en
contracte radio avec la fusée en
permanence et on voit aussi sur ce sur
ces espèces de timeline je sais pas
comment dire en français
c'est beaucoup plus simple une
chronologie visuelle avec les
différentes étapes avec les différentes
séparations et jusqu'à je pense
l'ouverture des panneaux solaires qui
est la dernière et en fait oui oui on a
on a sur ce vol là on a une phase
critique là de poussée d'Ariane 5 qui
dure 27 minutes
et on voit on voit les antennes radio là
sur la chronologie en bas effectivement
en fait on a un passage on a deux
passages de relais radio
avec au moment où on a traversé
l'Atlantique ou la fusée à travers
l'Atlantique est passé au-dessus de
l'Afrique il faut changer le relais
radios donc il y a des agences spatiale
européenne un des antennes radio qui
sont destinés à faire le suivi des
lancements pour ça exprès
donc là on voit tous les paramètres sont
bons
j'ai l'impression vitesse
altitude tout continue en tout cas comme
comme prévu
distance vitesse que vous pouvez le voir
3 km seconde quand même oui oui oui on
est
la vitesse de cette situation là c'est
autour de 11 km par seconde donc on a
encore pas mal d'accélérateurs à voir
mais on va déjà oui il y a des vitesses
qui sont
10000 km/h en fait tant que le moteur
est allumé la fusée ne cesse pas
d'accélérer elle accélère en continu
d'accord c'est donc en fait le moment
elle va plus vite c'est même pas aux
différents
mais en fait non elle va beaucoup plus
vite finalement pour aller dans l'espace
oui en fait plus spectaculaire c'est
quand on décolle quand on s'extrait de
l'attraction terrestre c'est vrai c'est
quelqu'un assez étonnant
mais on voit d'ailleurs que les
ingénieurs ils sont toujours aussi
concentrés aujourd'hui à ce moment-là
que qu'avant que ça décolle en fait la
vision est pas terminée il faut que ça
pousse il faut que ça pousse assez
longtemps pour que la fusée à la vitesse
nécessaire pour que joose puisse partir
vers Jupiter c'est donc on n'aura pas
facile les 27 minutes il y aura toujours
un petit doute mais là tout fonctionne
parfaitement et puis rien que c'est
quand même une diffusée les plus fiables
au monde donc on est moche j'ai aucune
inquiétude sur sur le bol de mon déroulé
de la mission est-ce que dans ces cas-là
tout est automatique on peut piloter
sur le papier en fait il y a que la
pomme qui gère le pâtir qui a qui a le
dernier mot finalement sur ce qui va se
passer oui oui en fait tant tant qu'on a
la chronologie même de compte à rebours
elle est automatique donc la tension
humaine elle peut intervenir jusqu'à je
crois une minute avant le décollage
après c'est soit l'ordinateur de bord
trouve qu'il y a un défaut il arrête
tout soit c'est parti on peut plus rien
faire c'est parti ça a l'air de 5 une un
lanceur qui est très comment dire qui
qui est très fiable hyper fiable qui a
été pendant des années
vraiment le la fusée européenne qui a
lancé le plus de satellites qui étaient
longtemps leader sur le marché
commercial pour lancer les satellite qui
s'est fait dépasser par Falcon de
SpaceX mais ça c'est assez récent et là
c'est l'avant dernier lancement d'un 5
c'est aussi assez émouvant il va rester
un satellite de Télécom à lancer cette
année et à la fin de l'année on espère
la succession avec Ariane 6 mais qui a
pris du retard si j'ai bien pris du
retard donc qui aurait dû être lancé
l'année dernière et on espère qu'on aura
lancement 2023 peut-être début du 24 ça
permettra
c'était surtout un lanceur conçu pour
être plus économique d'accord
c'est le top du top c'est la très très
haute mécanique dans tous les domaines
c'est fantastique Ariane 6 ça a été
conçu pour être plus facile à fabriquer
le moteur a été simplifié on garde la
même performances avec un peu plus de
simplification de production moins cher
qu'on essaie de faire un peu moins cher
et faire aussi bien mais le vrai
problème c'est que pendant le même
moment les américains ils ont inventé
une fusée à moitié réutilisable donc
beaucoup moins cher la concurrence est
très très rude avec Elon Musk qui
arrivait qui a quand même dynamité
complètement ce marché complètement il a
fait il a fait il a réussi ce que pas
mal d'ingénieurs pensaient être
impossible c'est-à-dire
récupérer première étage là on voit le
premier étage d'Ariane 5 qui continue de
fonctionner qui pousse qui emmène encore
12 vers Jupiter
et tout cet achat là sur Falcon 9 il est
récupéré il vient se reposer à la
verticale il y a quelques jours de
travail dessus et après il peut décoller
donc on a
SpaceX sur la concurrence il y a un
avantage qui va être difficile à
rattraper et
rien si ce qui arrive dans les mois
prochains en fait est déjà dépassé c'est
un peu c'est un peu triste enfin c'est
un peu difficile effectivement les
ingénieurs européens c'est
le moment difficile c'est on imagine
beaucoup de enfin beaucoup de d'émotions
aussi forcément je voudrais qu'on repart
alors là qu'est-ce qui vient de se
passer sur sur l'image on vient de le
voir c'est bien une nouvelle séparation
voilà on a séparation le premier étage
qui avait le moteur Vulcain qui est le
plus puissant des au décollage là il a
fini son travail et il se sépare il
reste plus que le deuxième étage qui lui
emporte
le
la sonde on voit à droite avec l'énorme
antenne la LED l'antenne de
télécommunications c'est pour parler
avec la terre
de Jupiter parce qu'il faut quand même
réussir à discuter avec nous quand on
est plus tard
et on voit on voit que là rien à
traverser l'Atlantique donc c'est quand
même assez rapide et on voit le moteur
là qui continue à pousser qui continue à
accélérer jusqu'au bout jusqu'à ce qu'on
soit à une vitesse oui on le voit
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on a dit qu'on
était à 3 km seconde on a 7 25 secondes
et au but c'est ça un peu plus que 10
oui et là on le voit sur la trajectoire
on est sur une phase
où on essaye de gagner un petit peu
d'altitude l'altitude va peut-être
légèrement baisser et pour gagner la
vitesse d'accord pour justement si on
peut en imagine mais c'est pas utile
mais on redescend pour pour accéder en
fait d'accord et donc là c'est ce qui se
passe et après on imagine que ça va
remonter une nouvelle fois une fois que
tu auras atteint ça la bonne après après
juste il va quitter l'orbite terrestre
donc il va oui il va s'éloigner elle va
elle sera plus en orbite autour de la
Terre on est sur une orbite de
libération on cherche à on cherche pas à
satelliser on cherche à
ce que la sonde soit complètement
libérée de l'attraction terrestre pour
partir plus loin oui et puis on va
d'ailleurs sur les sur ces
je vous le dis ça disparaît mais il y
avait cette chronologie on est encore
qu'au début
on est parti il y a 10 minutes et il
reste encore 17 minutes avant avant que
Karine s'est fait son travail et envoyé
mais
on a vécu je pense avec vous les moments
les plus les plus importants de cette
mission toutes les phases de séparation
sont cruciales sont les phases
dynamiques
le fonctionnement du moteur première
étage
d'incertitude peu d'inconnu donc je suis
vraiment confiant sur ce qui va se
passer on peut rappeler pour notre qui
était pas là au début tout de même ce
que ça à quoi va servir cette cette
sonde qu'on envoie jusqu'à Jupiter c'est
une sonde d'exploration c'est une
dizaine d'instruments scientifiques
consul depuis les années et pour on va
essayer d'étudier les lunes les plus
étonnantes du système solaire les lignes
glacée de Jupiter donc c'est elle
s'appelle Europe Ganymède et Callisto
elles font elles sont là elles sont plus
grosses que notre Lune elles sont
presque par la plus grosse presque aussi
grosse que mars donc c'est des lunes
mais elles sont quelque part presque des
planètes
Jupiter c'est immense c'est immense mais
c'est que du gaz c'est l'hydrogène et
l'hélium la surface
et c'est lui ne sont rocheuses elles
sont elles sont bien solides et elles
ont un des océans liquides qui en font
des cibles hyper intéressantes pour
étudier des environnements où la vie
peut-être apparue qui sait où est encore
présente aujourd'hui enfin et on imagine
d'ailleurs que c'est des cellules si
Jupiter est aussi gros que ça d'avoir
une puissance pour pour attirer les
objets assez grands aussi oui en fait
l'énergie l'énergie qui permet de
réchauffer ces lunes à une licence aussi
loin que Jupiter on est quand même 600
millions de kilomètres donc on est cinq
fois la distance
Terre-Soleil
le rayonnement du soleil est beaucoup
plus faible et donc pour chauffer
l'intérieur de ces lunes en fait c'est
les effets de marée de Jupiter la
planète est énorme elle est hyper
massive
et en fait il y a un écart de gravité
entre la partie éloignée de la lune et
la partie proche de la lune ce qui est
proche de Jupiter et c'était cette
différence de gravitation elle suffit à
déformer la lune et en gros à au fur et
à mesure malaxer la malaxer à la faire
changer de forme et ça ça réchauffe
c'est à dire que on est à la marée sur
terre ça déplace l'océan sur les côtes
là ça c'est l'ensemble de la lune qui
est déformée c'est comme si la lune
s'écrasait de temps en temps
c'est pas visible à l'oignon mais c'est
c'est vraiment des déformations d'accord
de structure interne et qui et c'est ça
qui donne l'énergie qui permet d'avoir
des océans liquides à la température
extérieure et de moins 100°c
ou la vie peut se
apparaître puisqu'il peut apparaître
parce qu'il y a de l'eau mais nous être
humain on pourrait pas y aller
il faut aussi rappeler que ce qu'on dit
parce ce qu'on veut dire qu'on dit qu'il
y a de la vie là-bas on imagine la vie
on imagine ben on imagine oui on imagine
d'abord
dans le plus fou ça serait une vie mais
microbienne déjà ce serait
extraordinaire passer de l'inerte au
vivant à l'échelle d'une bactérie c'est
déjà d'une complexité biologique
incroyable donc mais déjà et voir quand
on dit étudier l'émergence de la vie on
sait qu'elle existe sur Terre on est là
on est la preuve et le signe mais en
fait allez voir sur Europe et sur
ganymètre ces océans souterrains c'est
aussi étudier la chimie qui peut se
produire au contact entre la croûte qui
est déformée réchauffée par les marées
et l'océan on sait qu'il faut qu'il y
ait de l'énergie il faut qu'il
pour l'apparition du vivant il faut
qu'il ait contact entre du minéral et
l'eau liquide pour mélanger tout ça
enfin c'est c'est une chimie qu'on
essaie de comprendre mais sur lequel on
a que des embryons d'idées donc tout est
bon pour apprendre en fait aussi tout
est bon pour apprendre et comme le dit
Jean-François
destination et l'une de Jupiter arrivée
en 2031 merci beaucoup Cyril d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous suivre
financement pour nous pour nous éclairer
sur ce qui est passé si vous voulez
retrouver ce lancement bien évidemment
vous le retrouvez sur le site du Figaro
vous pouvez retrouver les images c'était
assez impressionnant comme d'habitude
pour on le rappelle aussi de la vente
dernier lancement de Ariane 5 avant
l'arrivée sur Ariane 6 et voilà donc les
acquis qui qui diffusent eux aussi au
fait voilà il montre aussi quand même à
quoi ça va ressembler en anglais tout à
l'heure juste ces immenses panneaux
solaires
les panneaux solaires ils sont ils sont
gigantesque 85 mètres carrés donc c'est
sur deux cours de tennis un terrain de
basket
il faut que ça reste très léger parce
que c'est un objet qui décolle par une
fusée de toute façon costaud on voyait
aussi pas mal d'antenne il y a
énormément de d'instruments de mesure
magnétiques et électromagnétiques parce
que Jupiter
un champ magnétique hyper puissant très
complexe intéressant ce qui est aussi
compliqué qui complique la mission parce
qu'il y a des ceintures de radiation qui
sont extrêmement destructrices et
violente notamment pour la lune Europe
ou européenne de la faire que de
survoles c'est la zone vraiment
dangereuse c'est les instruments de bord
sont blindés avec le moment avec du
blindage du plomb du plomb pour protéger
l'électronique d'accord
de Jupiter donc environnement hyper
hostile on voit les lignes de champ
magnétiques on voit les lunes voilà donc
c'est une mission avec plein de défis
comment fournir d'électricité aussi loin
de la terre aussi loin du soleil
et communiquer donc on a vu la taille
une immense centaine radio qui fait plus
de 2 mètres de diamètre on la voit sur
le côté là
voilà c'est le top parce que c'est faire
l'Europe aujourd'hui en terme
d'exploration et c'était lancé par an 5
de Guyane avec un lancement magnifique
pour le moment tout se passe
parfaitement et d'ailleurs je voulais
juste montrer aussi on avait la coupe
tout à l'heure on a vu qu'on a mon est
monté après on est redescendu on disait
pour prendre de vitesse et là on remonte
une nouvelle fois
voilà donc la vitesse on est à 8,5 km/s
on est plus très loin de la vitesse
finale et là on regagne de la de
l'altitude
voilà mais on est on est enchant qu'on a
déjà survolé l'Afrique donc on est parti
de Guyane
c'est moins de 5 minutes et voilà ça va
vite ça va très très vite ça va beaucoup
plus vite que n'importe quel vol
commercial
d'ailleurs je vous renvoie vous pouvez
retrouver d'ailleurs sur ceux qui
regardent sur youtube il y a les liens
des articles écrits par Tristan V sur
justement c'est l'une c'est assez
impressionnant tout est expliqué dans
ces
articles Stéphane c'est fini le
lancement oui le lancement avait lieu à
14h14 il s'est a priori très bien passé
de en tout cas jusque là tout va bien
vous pouvez retrouver d'ailleurs ces
images on vous l'a dit sur le site du
Figaro merci une nouvelle fois Cyril
d'avoir été avec nous de rien faire ça
et on va vous laisser avec un peu ces
images et on vous dit à bientôt sur
figaroline